Alors déjà,
les sondages nous donnent en moyenne à 6% hein.
Donc aujourd'hui, 6% c'est 6 députés européens.
Et je pense que tout le monde doit se garder, euh.
De considérer que le
les sondages d'aujourd'hui
seront les résultats électoraux demain.
je pense que vous êtes des observateurs de la vie
politique,
vous souvenez qu'aux dernières élections, on se
l'écologiste Yannick Jado était à 5,
6. Tout au long de la campagne,
il aura fini à 13 et à l'inverse,
François Xavier bélamique était à 15, puis 13,
aura fini à 8.
Tout le monde sait qu'évidemment,
rien n'est écrit en en 3 mois de campagne,
donc moi je suis convaincu,
vous le verrez, que nous, nous serons euh.
Créé la la surprise.
Vous visez combien ?
Vous visez combien de députés ?
Je me fixe pas 1 objectif de député,
je fixe d'avoir des élus
et que le mouvement que je représente
et que les idées que je défends et.
Et je vais y revenir tout de suite,
soit le plus, les plus,
les mieux représentés,
avec la maximum d'élus au Parlement européen,
pour 1 raison simple,
c'est qu'aujourd'hui reconquête appartient à 1 groupe
européen qui s'appelle le CR,
les conservateurs européens.
Le CR, c'est 17 nationalités, c'est 4 gouvernements,
probablement 5 avec le Victor Orban.
Au lendemain des élections,
c'est le groupe le plus influent à droite,
c'est le groupe qui peut faire et
défaire la majorité demain au Parlement européen
et qui peut battre le groupe des Macronistes,
donc, c'est 1 groupe qui est, euh,
incontournable et décisif dans la nouvelle majorité
demain, que nous pouvons installer,
et reconquête à donc 1 rôle
important demain,
pour pouvoir passer d'une Union européenne,
aujourd'hui, gouverner par le centre et la gauche,
voilà, depuis des décennies, hein,
euh, à 1 Union européenne, gouverner, euh,
à droite,
oui, enfin, moi, je considère que là, je parle du centre.
Objectivement, le ppe,
euh, on a fait, vous avez raison, qui est le groupe D, L, R,
euh, qui est, euh,
qui est, pour moi, au centre, et qui est allié, euh,
au PS, euh,
ponctuellement, aux écologistes et aux macronistes.
C'est la majorité d'ursela vanderlion aujourd'hui.